(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] The armed
insurrection launched
by the chief of the
paramilitary Wagner Group,
Yevgeny Prigozhin, lasted less than a day,
but it was the biggest challenge
to the rule of the Russian president.
(Vladimir Putin Speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] On Saturday, Wagner seized
the southern military
district headquarters
in the city of Rostov,
the main logistical hub
for Russian forces operating in Ukraine.
They were rolling towards Moscow
when a deal set to be negotiated
by the Belarusian president
between Prigozhin and Putin averted
a potential confrontation.
The Wall Street Journal's Moscow
bureau chief, Ann Simmons,
explains what the short-lived
mutiny means for Putin.
- This crisis is the
most significant test,
I believe, that Putin has
faced in his 23 year rule.
Putin had to back down
to a certain degree,
because he had to go to
the negotiating table.
In the morning on Saturday,
we had Vladimir Putin accusing Prigozhin
of instigating an armed rebellion.
By the evening, we were
seeing that Prigozhin
is forgiven and the charge is dropped.
Now, we do not know
what kind of deal
Prigozhin got out of this,
it is said that he will
be going to Belarus,
but the Russian population has now seen
that President Putin isn't as invincible.
This is definitely exposed vulnerability
of his power in the eyes
of the Russian elite.
In terms of what this crisis shows,
it shows that there was
very little resistance
to Prigozhin on his way to Moscow.
The very fact that
Prigozhin and his troops
were able to get within striking distance
of Moscow speaks volumes.
It shows on the one hand that soldiers
in the Russian military
maybe weren't willing
to take up arms against Prigozhin.
His force is quite feared,
and we also have to note
that a large portion
of Russia's army is now on
the front lines of Ukraine.
Also, there were pictures and videos
of people actually greeting
Prigozhin and his troops,
at least in Rostov in the south,
that shows that maybe there
is this level of support
for Prigozhin that Putin
probably underestimated.
The question now will be, how
does vladimir Putin regain
the narrative that despite
that slight glitch,
"Nothing has changed, I still have power."
But it's definitely clear that his power,
at least the perception of
his power, has been eroded.